- Wait, what?
- I have no idea.
- Does somebody want to tell me something?
(bright pop music)
- 23.
- 30.
- 26.
- 29.
- 27.
- 26.
- 24.
- 27.
- 25?
- My what?
- What?
- My Korean age? Uhh...
- What does that even mean?
- I don't know what that question means.
- I don't know! (laughing)
- I'm 31 in Korean.
- 28 in Korea.
- I'm 25.
- 25.
- 27?
- I'm 25.
- In Korean age I'm 24.
- I'm 26 in Korea.
- They're different?
- They have different ages?
- Is that a thing?
- Why?
- How does that work?
(bright pop music)
(Gasps)
- Oh wow, okay.
- That's crazy.
- That makes sense.
- I'm older!
- I'm just getting over the
fact that I just turned 26,
can you like give me a
second to fucking process
that before you tell me I'm 27!
(cheering)
- Well how bout that!
- Legal in my home country.
You gotta give me all the booze!
- Probably prefer my age
here cause I'm younger.
- I like 24 better than 25.
- I prefer my age here.
- I'm younger here.
- Who wants to be older?
Unless you're like, 12.
- Oh I like my age here.
- I'm gonna stick with 30.
- I wanna be young forever.
- I need about half the year
I have left to feel okay
about turning 30.
- Well I'm glad I'm in America. (laughing)
- Their music is too like, mind blowing
that you age a little bit.
- That's how cool Koreans are.
- They have their own age.